alors comme nous sommes sur le point de
remettre le très attendu césar du
meilleur acteur
je profite de ce moment qui m'est donnée
pour enfin que je me donne pour prendre
un petit peu la défense des hommes
voilà je trouve que les hommes sont très
attaquées en ce moment on leur reproche
beaucoup de choses et et ils ont pas le
temps souvent d'exprimer leur défense
voilà et je pense que ce serait quand
même la moindre des choses que de les
laisser le temps de s'expliquer voilà
j'ai enfin on sait tous que récemment un
acteur a été accusé de 2,7 me tout nu
devant sa masseuse et ah oui mais il
avait peut-être des bonnes raisons donc
voilà je vois là moi je suis allé
fouiller un peu dans la presse et voilà
j'ai lu en effet ces raisons il dit pour
sa défense je cite j'avais chaud bah
ouais mais j'aimerais oui j'ai vérifié
il faisait chaud on était encore en
plein été j'ai pas si vous avez déjà
essayé d'enfiler un slip jetables 29
degrés est c'est très complet a besoin
de table moi je te lis un peuple j'ai
fait le test dans la linge à 25 déjà je
pouvais plus voilà donc je pense qu'on
pourrait peut-être faire le
rapprochement entre réchauffement
climatique et ses comportements non mais
je sais pas ils ont peut-être mais
peut-être enfin l'andropause quelque
chose pourquoi hier avec nous qu'ils
auraient des bouffées de chaleur enfin
je veux dire qui tous ces mecs-là qui
ont le même mode opératoire d'ailleurs
de se [ __ ] à poil c'est très étonnant
devant nous c'est peut-être juste voilà
un dérèglement climatique intérieure
qu'on entend quoi
mais évidemment winstein show hip stein
show dsk chou [ __ ] mais ouvrez les
yeux merde il y en a pas d'écart en
alaska en sibérie donc voilà on se
détend on les ai eues mais en tout cas
c'est comme ça que je m'explique le mode
opérateurs de se mettre tout nu parce
que si c'est dans l'espoir de nous
exciter oui la haye
j'avais l'image ou pas non je sais pas
peut-être que comment peuvent-ils
espérer un quart de seconde que à la vue
de leurs irrésistibles anatomique va
buzzer
oh mon dieu qu'est ce que c'est non mais
j'ai chaud mais aussi parce qu'il me
prend pas
qu'est ce que c'est que ça j'ai envie de
le prendre dans ma bouche et de
m'étouffer avec mon dieu
oui non les gars vous aurez plus de
chances de nous chauffer avec un bout de
pain voilà je voulais juste n'avait
demandé la nullité d'un la nudité ne va
pas à tout le monde ça ces seuils en
cabine avant voilà passé un certain âge
et un certain poids couvrez-vous moi
j'ai tendance à penser que wayne stein
est peut-être un peu plus séduisant
habillé en tout cas - dégueulasse 1
voilà c'était mon petit conseil aux
futurs prédateurs couvrez-vous